よろしくお願いします
Dūra
ṃ gamam ekacaraṃ asarīraṃ guhāsayam. Ye cittaṃ saññam
essanti mukkhanti mārabandhanā.
Dūraṃ gamam ekacaraṃ asarīraṃ guhāsayam. Ye cittaṃ saññamessanti
mukkhanti mārabandhanā.
という えっと 偈です それもね
心の状況を説明しているところで
まずは意味を考えてみます Dūraṃ
gamamというのはよく
まあ遠く 行く もう走るということで
まあ遠くへ行く 長旅するということで ekacaraṃ
というのは一人で行くんですね
かなり遠くへ行くんですけど
しかし一人で勝手に行くんです asarīraṃ
というのは まあ体は持ってない guhāsayam
というのはなかなかこれは定義ができないところになってます guhā
というのは洞窟なんですけど
まあ洞窟の中に住んでるんだというね
まあ住処は洞窟であるということなんです
で それはどういうことかというと cittaṃ
その心のことなんですね
その心をye 誰かがsaññamessanti
制御するならば mukkhanti
mārabandhanā
悪魔の束縛から自由に解放されますよ
ということで まあ少々まあ文学的な
一応心のことで Dūraṃ
gamamというところはまあなんとなくわかりやすいですね
遠くへ行くんだと いわゆる心には距離的には制限がないんですね
まあそんなに難しいことではなくて
まあどんなものでも思い浮かぶことはできます
瞬時に頭の中で思い浮かぶことはできるんですね
ですから 別に心には距離感ということはあまりないんですね
だから今こちらにいながら
まあ瞬時に大阪のことを思い出すことはできますし
新潟のことを思い出すことはできますし
体で経験しようとすると
やっぱり距離というものはもう関係があって
時間かけて大阪まで行かなくちゃいけないんですね
体で経験しようと思うと
頭で考えてみようと思っちゃうと
別に瞬時に考えられますね
そういうことはDūraṃ gamamということで ekacaraṃ
というのは一人で歩くということでね
心を動かせるために他何か必要なわけじゃないんです
で 何かがあって心が動いてるわけじゃない
例えば 北海道に住んでいる人と話したいというならば
簡単に話せるでしょうに
しかし 私たちが北海道にいる人と簡単にしゃべるのは
電話というある機械を通してなんですね
だから電話という機械がなければ
北海道にいる人とはしゃべることはできませんし
アメリカにいる人ともしゃべることはできないんですね
だから現代人にはアメリカにいる人ともしゃべられます
こちらにいながら しかし
直接勝手ではできないんです
何か道具を使わなくちゃいけないんですね
電話という道具を使わなくちゃいけない
そうすると電話がもういろんな方法でそちらとつなげているんだから
そこでしゃべってるんですね
だから音というものが
やっぱり何かの物質として伝わってくるんです
それと比べると 心はそういうふうに何かを通して伝わるものじゃないっていうことです
電波も電線も何も要りませんと
エーカチャラ 自分一人で行くんです
それはすごい大変特殊で
今の時点で理解できるということは
別に何もなくても何か考えることはできるでしょうに
皆様の実家のことを考えると
実家のことを思い出すためにはこれ必要です
あれ必要ですってないでしょうに
では 母のことを思い出してみようか
母のことを思い出そうと思ったら
家に置いている置物がなければできませんよとか
そういうことはないでしょうに
何も 何て言いますか 道具は必要ないんです
では 母のことを思い出しましょうと思っちゃうと
瞬時に思い出せるんです
道具は要りません 何一つ
その意味なんです エーカチャラって
心だけでできます アサリイランっていうのは
事実心には体がないんです
形がないんです だから心に全く物質ではないんです
色も形も重さも何もない
形ないということは空間取ってないっていうことなんです
ナノミリぐらいの空間も取らないんです
だからもう心はどういうものかと人間には考えることできないんですよと
だから場所は取らないんだったら
[音楽]それはなかなか人間に考えることはできないんです
我々はどこにあるのかという場所で考えているんだからね
よくみんな聞くんだよ
心はどこにあるのかと
その時点でもう答えられないんですよ
何が輪廻転生するのかとかね
質問自体があんまりにもおかしいんですよ
わかりやすく言えば ウサギの角の重さを言ってくださいと
ウサギの角の重さ言ってくださいと言っても
どれぐらい言えばいいんですかね
それはちょっと説明難しいんですから
勝手に説明しますけど
例えばウサギの角の重さが言ってくださいと言ったら
とにかく答えなさいと言っちゃうと
大体人っていうのはゼロだよと言うかもしれませんよ
どれぐらい重いんだ？ゼロ
ウサギの角の重さはどれぐらいですかね
ゼロと言ったら それはとんでもない間違いなんで
ゼロっていうのは価値ですからね
ゼロとも言えないし 重さがないとも言えないんです
何言ったっても ウサギの角の実態を認めなきゃ答えられないものなんです
だから ありともしない
存在もしないものについては
もうどんな質問したって答えられるはずがないんです
人間が頭の中でそういういっぱい概念を作って
存在しない概念はものすごい大量に作って
それで生きていて それはあれやこれやとかね
言ってるだけのことで
ものすごい話が通じないんですね
我々頭の中で作っている概念もほとんどウサギの角のようなもので
実際しないもので この実際しないものをいっぱい頭に叩き込んで
それで話し合ったりする
例えばウサギの角を認めたところでいくらでも喋りますから
これは長いか短いか 細いか太いかとかね
鹿のように皮膚に覆っているかないかとかね
いくらでも喋られますけど
どちらでももうお互いに話し合うだけで
そうではないか そうではないかというだけで終わっちゃうんです
推測できます ウサギはいっぱい毛があるんだから
もしかすると鹿と同じく角が皮膚で覆っているかもしれませんと
あるいはもう一人 いえ
違います 他の小さな同じ動物にも角がありますけど
その時はとげみたいな小さくあるだけですから
いえ 違いますよ あれは
あの なんとかみんな虫食ってるでしょ
あれなんていう虫？カブトムシ
クワガタのような感じのものだよとかね
何でも言えます だから
どんどんどんどんそうやって話だけ膨らませて膨らませて
もう大量に本やらデータやらもう世の中ではあるんです
いろんなものについて
なんでそんなにも大量に知識っていうのがあるんですかね
あれは知識じゃないんだからなんです
いくらでも増える 小説と同じなんです
いくらでも書ける そういうことで
そんな話は関係ないんですけど
今説明したものは存在しないってことだから
我々は何かあるあるって考えて考えているんだから
やっぱり心もあると言った途端
どこにあるのかという疑問が当然頭に浮かんでくるんですけど
それはもう単純に妄想の結果で
心には場所がないんです
体がないんです 体がないっていうことはすごい大胆な言葉で
原子一個ぐらいには体がないんです
心っていうのは原子ぐらい小さいんだと
ああ そうですかとか なんとか変なことを言うかもしれませんです
原子も知ってる 知ってるわけじゃないでしょうし
原子の存在でも人間に経験することはできんですよ
どんな機械使っても で
原子自体はエネルギーですから
まあまあまああるということは
他の方法で他の手段を使ってあるんだぞというね
ことは推測できるんですけど
直視することはできません
まあそれよりも小さいだよとか何とか言ったっても何の意味もないんです
全くも心には体がない
形がない ふーん グハーサヤンということはどう説明すればいいかということはちょっとわからないんですね
自分に体がないんですけど
住むところはあるんですね
要するに住むところは何かお釈迦様がよくグハという言葉を使ってますね
グハっていうのは洞窟ということで
これはこの このインドのバラモン連中以外
この数少ないすごい哲学者で
仙人たちの間で合った言葉なんです
あの この多種派のバラモン系では
そういう概念なんか使ってたわけじゃないんです
だからこの だから明確な意味は出てこないんです
ある何人かの仙人方の間で修行を進んでいる
瞑想を進んでいる 仏教だけではなくて
他の宗教にもそういう方
人々がいましたから そういう人々の間で交わしていた
もうちょっとした単語なんだと思いますけどね
だからこれが一番古い経典なんかにも出てくるものでね
グハという言葉はね スッタニパータにサットグハヤンバフナービッチャンノというところから始まる四行偈
四行の偈がありまして
うーん お釈迦様はその四行を言ってサーリプッタ尊者にあなたこれ解説できますかと
言うとサーリプッタ尊者もそれはちょっとと言うんですね
言うと お釈迦様がまあちょっとヒントを一つ与えるんです
ヒントを与えた途端 サーリプッタ尊者がよくわかりました
では解説しますということで解説するんです
だからそれぐらいグハという言葉っていうのは難しい単語になっているんです
まあそれはスッタニパータに出てくることだから
日本の方々みんなもう朝飯ぐらいの感じで読んでいるでしょうね
日本訳ありますから まあその経典の説明では
まあグハというのはもう単純にこの体肉体
体肉体というような意味で十分です
だからその中でそれを住処にしている
体を だから住所は体ですけど
体の中にどこにいるのかというと
こちらに体がないんだから空間取らないんですよ
だから あ 心は今こちらにいて
今別なところに行っていますよとかね
体の中で歩いているんだったら
それでも言えるでしょうね
それはわからないんです
もう別に心自体には体がないんだから
例えば寄生虫でも体の中にいるんだったら
そちらに寄生虫にも体があるんだから
どこにいるのかわかるんですよ
例えばウイルスでも体に入ったならば
そのウイルスにも体があるでしょうに
だからどこにいるんでしょうかということは
調べることは可能です
体がないんだったら調べることはできない
しかし 体の中に住んでいるんです
だから そこら辺のはすごく普通の人間の頭では理解しにくいことになっているんです
堂々と体の中に住んでいるんですけど
これが心ですというふうに取り出してあげることはもう難しい
絶対難しい で 体がないんだからこそ距離感がないんです
うーん それでまあ時間関係は心にはやっぱりありますけど
まあそれでもね そんなにそれにこだわることなく
まあ動くことはできます
要するに意味はそれ そういう意味なんですね
心は遠く旅立つ しかし
一人でいる 体もない 自分には体がないんだけど
体の中に住んでいる 理解する方法っていうのはないんですからね
こういう例えで考えても理解はできないと思いますけど
例えば針を持って 誰かが自分の手をちょっと刺してみる
針で刺すと痛い  ちょっとあの
あまりにも鋭い針だったら体の中に入りますから
まあちょっと普通のピンとかね
あるいはこの 何でしたっけ
短針という指で押すやつあるでしょ
あれなんて言いますか
画鋲とかね 例えば画鋲
画鋲をもう体に押すと
まあ押すともうまあ別に太いんだから体の中に入ることはないんですけど
もう結構痛いんですね
この痛みというのは心の一部なんですね
心がなければ痛みは感じないんです
そこでその痛んでいるその場所には一応心が機能しているんです
ではそこで見つかるのかというと
物質的に見ると見つからないんですね
ただ圧力かけちゃって
神経が圧迫されちゃって
そこで電気信号がという
なんとか生まれて そこはもう脳に伝達されちゃって
脳からまた逆に答えが出てくるだけのことです
だから脳で痛み感じるんだと
脳で痛みを感じると頭が痛くてたまらなくなるはずなんですけど
でも医者はこれは脳で感じるんだよと言うんですね
どう見たっても脳は痛み感じるはずがないんです
そんな体中の痛みやら痒みから何でも脳が感じる脳
脳っていうのは大変ですよ
脳は何も感じないんです
脳の手術する場合は何のことなく直接手術するんです
それやりながら医者が言うのは
それは脳が感じるんだと
だからそこら辺は科学者の理屈と仏教の理屈はなかなか噛み合わないんですね
我々から見れば なんだかんだや脳感じるんだったら
脳の手術なんかできるはずがないんです
脳がそこで爆発してパニックになるんでしょうね
こんなに我々毎日どれほど音を感じたり
ものを見たり 体で痛み感じたり
あるいはそれ全部脳が自分一人で頑張ってるんだと言えば
よく耐えるものですよ
あれが 脳で感じないんですよ
ただもう画鋲を手におしたところで
もうそこは物質的に圧力かけているんですね
そこで細胞がもう抑えられているでしょうに
それで神経も抑えられているでしょうに
その抑えられたエネルギーに不調和
すぐ電気信号生まれて
それまた物質でしょうに
そこが脳に行って 脳からまた別な反応という電気信号が至る所に行くだけ
それで物質的にはそうやってまた回路が出来上がっちゃうんですよ
だってインプットされたらどうしてもアウトプットしなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それで画鋲を押されたっていうことはインプットなんですね
物質的なエネルギーのインプット
それは別な物質のエネルギーとしてアウトプットされるんです
出力するんです どこに痛みがあるんですかね
痛み自体は心の一部なんです
では 心の働きはどういう働きかというと
決してそのシステムの中にあるわけじゃないんです
システムを媒介はしているんですけど
システムの中にいないんです
いないではなくているんですけど
体がないんだから もう決して科学的に発見できるものじゃないんです
物体ではないんだから
だから見事に画鋲を左手に押したところで
ちゃんとその場所が痛いんであって
決して右足は痛くなりませんよ
脳である一箇所で痛み感じるんだったら
なんで場所がわかってるんですかね
体ひねるたびに脳が痛み感じるんだったら
脳の一箇所でしょ 痛み感じるの
そうすると体どこを触っても一箇所痛いはずなんです
それがないでしょうに
だから脳の中ではちゃんと体の図形がありますけど
全体的に であって まあそれなりに情報がつなげてサーキット作るだけであって
それで痛み感じる場所があるんだといっても
たとえいくらサーキットあったっても
その場所が痛いはずなんです
そんなことはないんです
だから画鋲が 画鋲が押したんだから痛いという物質的な原因があるんだから
画鋲を発した瞬間で もう痛みもなくなっちゃうんですね
そちらにあえて別に心は生まれてしまったんです
なんか異常現象来たんだから
異常現象がなくなったらそちらにも心は機能しなくなるだけ
だから心というのは明らかにあるものなんですけど
まあどうしても世界の学問では理解できるものでも
説明できるものでも全くもない
実際にはもう心はメインに働いているものなんですね
だから体がないということはなかなか大変なことなんです
うん だから現代人には仏教を理解するということはかなり至難の業だと思います
唯物論しか勉強したことはないんだから
それそれで悪くないんですけど
それこそ至上台と思っているでしょうに
それで自分では有名なバカの壁を作って
それ以外はないと そういうバカの壁あるんだと言っている人も
強烈な壁を作っているんです
もしかすると普通の人の壁よりはかなりひどいかもしれません
それ以外はもうなしと
だからこの唯物論だばっかり勉強しちゃって
それこそ至上最高な知恵だと
知識やと それで自分たちに壁を作っているんだから
そのバリアを破って知恵を開発することはもう不可能ということになっているんです
最初から物質を媒介しないで物事を考える能力をね
子供の時から身につけば
それはそれなりの知恵の文化ですからね
インド文化ではもう天文学も星もあれこれとか全部発展していたでしょうね
でも図はないんですよ
現代人の天文学であろうか
数学であろうか もうもう数は書くわ書くわ書くわ
文字を書く もうそれでぐちゃぐちゃ計算しているでしょうね
それ何一つもなくやっているんだから
どうやってやっているんですかね
やっていたんだから またもう文字に戻ってしまったんですけど
遠い昔もちゃんと知ってますよ
どんな日にちで日食が起こるか
どんな日に月食が起こるのかとかね
しかし 展望台ももう何もない
それで厳しい数学計算するでしょうに
しかし 日本で使っているあれさえもない
何でしたっけ？そろばんさえも
だからこの無限大という数字が
いとも簡単に我々は無数アサンケイヤという数字とかね
何のことなく使ってますけど
それは 10のもう10の300何とか乗やと言ったって分からないでしょうね
そんな形で言ったっても
このアサンゲイヤというこの一番もう計算できると一番高いところなんで
そこまでちゃんとチャートまであるんですよ
それも暗記するもんですけど 10
とか 10 100 1000 10
万 何とか何とか何とか言っていて
そこでもう最後にアサンケイヤという無数という
量帯数ですか  うん だからそこは 1に来て計算したり
またするし だから頭だけでやってますからね
このスケールの取り方っていうのはね
かなり違うんですよ その文化は
それできたのはこの確実に全て物質だよというふうなことから
初めも思ってないんです
物質はほんの一部でいいや
そんなのはということで
もう軽々く見るんですね
軽々く処理するものは
もうそれこそ絶対的 唯一というふうに言ったところで
かなり壁がついちゃったんですね
知恵が開発しないように
それが問題なんですね
時々もう飽きてしまう時もありますけど
偉そうにすごい頭があるそうに喋るんですけど
だから肩書持ってるんだから
こちらもえらい遠慮はするんで
こちら何の肩書きもないんだから
世界にありったけの学問で肩書
それちょっと待ってと考えちゃうと
こいつは幼稚園の子供言わないほどバカじゃないかなと思ったりする時もあります
今まで何を勉強していた人でしょうかと
肩書きで押さえようとしてるんで
だから世間は肩書ない私を認めませんだから私も黙っていなくちゃいけないんです
別に世間のことを気にしてるわけじゃないんですけど
まあ余計な批判しちゃうと私は攻撃するんだからね
面倒くさいんですよ この攻撃するの
どうせ相手にならない人間だから面白くもないし
どうせ面と向かって攻撃しないでしょうに
隠れてでしょうに だから面倒くさいんだからもうやらないんで黙ってるんです
やっぱりまああの 驚くほど頭が
なんだこれという風に
人が喋ってると もう明らかにこれ嘘でしょうと
人の話の中で見えてるのをみんな「ああそうですか」という風に認めちゃうんですね
あれがちょっと我々にとっては
時々もうなんか首がやっぱり曲がっちゃうね
これで なんだこれと これで知識じゃない
やっぱり逆に考えてみれば
それはやっぱり無理な話ではないんですよ
まあテレビで流れたそれこそ真実そのものや
新聞で出たらそれこそ真実そのものやということでしょうに
新聞で書くのだって ある人間書くものでしょうに
その人を調べて書くか勝手に書くか
誰がわかるんですかね
その人に問われた同胞でもそのまま書いたっても
それは本当の情報か誰がわかるんですかね
あるいは記者が書いて出しても
編集のところで編集しちゃったらどうするんですかね
だから決して真理にならないのに
それこそ真理という風になっちゃうんです
だから研究レポートやら論文やら考察も真理になりませんよ
もういい加減なもんばっかしですからね
まあなのに まあねつ造するということを科学者の世界でもかなりやってます
しかしそれは肩書きでもう全部パスなんです
まあだからそこは無理じゃないっていうのは
まああるこの我々知識にリミットをつけているんだから
そのリミットの中に入るものは全部真理だと
そういうことで 心っていうものは理解できないっていうことになってます
どんな風に例え持ってきたっても
これはもう無理です 物質的な例えですからね
だから心には体がない
それしか言えないんです
しかし  9 8 1,000体の中に住んでます
堂々と 体の中に住んでるんだから
体はただの家なんですよ
心の だから心が偉いんです
家が偉くないんです 家っていうのは
まあ普通は住んでる人によって偉くなるんであって
家によって人が偉くなることはないんです
普通だったら  [無音]だから有名な人とかね
かなりの大物の人々とかね
住んでるところはいろいろ警備やったり
立ち入り禁止にしたり
もうあるでしょうね その場所がすごいんだからじゃないんですよ
その中にいる人がすごいんだからなんです
東京にもちょっと行ったところで
かなりの面積を取っている場所があるでしょうに
中に入れないでしょうに
周りは回れますけど 別にその場所すごい尊い？そんなことないんで
そちらに住んでいる人が偉いんだから
ここからは入るなよと
それはかなりの遠くからも禁止されているんだから
そう入ったっても その人に会うことはできないし
もうまた車に乗って行かなくちゃいけないんだから
だからその住んでいる人が偉いんです
それで場所に価値がつくんです
そういうことで 体に心が住んでいるんだから
体に価値があるんです
でないと体に何の価値もないんです
私たちはもう自分の体に価値を入れてるでしょうに
しわが出たら大変だとかね
別にしわが出たって死んだ人はいませんだけど
もうしわが出たら大変だとかね
ちょっと関節がちょっと腫れてるんで
これどうでしょうかね
ちょっと調べなくちゃとかね
そういう風に ほんのちょっとの体の変化もすごく気になって
体を守る守るということは
結局は住んでいるやつを守るをしているだけなんです
建物が壊れたらもうもう大変だからね
別なところに行かなくちゃいけないんだから
だから住んでいる人は自分住んでいる家の処理をしているんです
そこは現代知識で錯覚して
体中心に生きてみようとするか
全部体体ばっかしで 何を開発したっても体の肉体のために
何か成長しようと思うと肉体の成長
肉体には成長がないってことを明らかに知っているのに
それでもやろうとしている
体の体力やら能力っていうのはものすごいほんのわずかで
もう決まってるんですからね
なのに もっともっともうなんかすごいもう超人
超人 超人 噂やってみようではないかと頑張るんですよ
そういう心で それはサンニャ・メッサンというこの心を調教したらどうでしょうかと
体ではなくてね その心そのものを制御すればどうでしょうかと
そこを心そのものを制御すると
死から死の苦しみから
あるいは悪魔から解放されますよ
マーラ・バンドナ マーラっていうのはマーラの悪魔のことで
その束縛から解放されます
マーラって言ったっても
決して人格視していることでは言ってるんではなくて
煩悩のことなんですね
だから心がいい加減だから我々は苦しんでいる
あらゆる煩悩を作って
感情を作って 煩悩 感情を作るのは物質的なものに定着しているし
それ自体意味もないし
体にはすごい執着しているし
執着していたって何のことはないし
体が壊れていくものです
それは認めないし だから体が当然壊れるんだから
すごくショックを受けちゃって
心が で またさっさと別な体で
もうまた機能始めるし
それ明らかに輪廻転生あるんで
何が輪廻転生しているのか探そうとする
探したって見つかりっこはないんだから
今ここで遺体なのに それの心でなのに
その心は何なのか説明つかないでしょうに
だから輪廻転生で説明つくわけないんです
だからその体の心にある愚かさを何とかしなさいっていうのは仏教の話なんです
心が愚か者だから 心の愚かさを
[終始背景音楽]